When we talk about contemporary Turkey we think
of the long career of the current president
Erdogan. But we will come slowly to talk about his
politics. First a little geography, which never
hurts. We are dealing with a nation in the middle
between Southeastern Europe and Western Asia,
divided into two peninsular regions: Eastern
Thrace and Anatolia, bordered to the northwest
by Greece and Bulgaria, to the south by Syria
and Iraq, and to the east by Iran, Armenia,
and Georgia. Thanks to its strategic location,
the country has positioned itself as a bridge
between different cultures, benefiting from
democratic influences from the Old Continent
and becoming a role model for all Middle Eastern
countries aspiring to a synthesis of Islam and the
rule of law. Now we are witnessing a reversal,
and the recent authoritarian drift has greatly
slowed down the process of establishing democratic
principles. We can say that the beginning of these
processes dates back to the late 19th century when
competition with European powers led some of the
cultural elites within the Ottoman Empire to push
for modernization. A goal that according to some
could be achieved by maintaining a synthesis
between Islamic faith and state institutions, but
which according to others, including the famous
Moustafa Kemal, required a clean break between
state and religion, which had to be limited to
the private sphere of the citizen. Thus, after
the 1923 elections that saw the victory of the
Republican People's Party (CHP) led by Ataturk,
Turkish became the official language in place
of Arabic, the form of state was revised in a
republican key, a head of state and a prime
minister appointed by the head of state were
established. Then within the following year, to
solve the problem of the difficult coexistence
between democracy and Islam, Islam was erased
from the country's daily life by abolishing the
sultanate, caliphate, and Islamic courts. This
wasn t such a clean exit, however, since despite
the forced secularization, Sunni Islam continued
to remain very deeply rooted, especially among the
rural and less educated population, also thanks
to the influence that religious brotherhoods have
always exerted on every aspect of society.
These include the Sufi-oriented Nak?ibendi,
to which Necmettin Erbakan, Erdogan's political
father, belonged, and the Hizmet, founded by
Fethullah Gulen, which Erdogan used to rise to
power and with which he came into open conflict
during the attempted coup of 2016. However, what
were the highlights of the Kemalist reforms?
With the establishment of the Republic of Turkey
on October 29, 1923, legislative and executive
powers passed into the hands of the Assembly,
which was responsible for electing the President
of the Republic, the head of the sole party, for
4-year terms. The head of state in turn appointed
the president of the council of ministers and
the members of the council itself. Completing
the picture were the stated independence of the
judiciary, the recognition of the formal equality
of citizens before the law, and the granting of
the active and passive vote to women. A milestone
achieved in 1934, long before several European
countries. But it was in 1937 that the most
important constitutional reform took place: the
one that defined the so-called 6 arrows of the
Turkish state: republican, nationalist, populist,
statist, reformist and secular. Ataturk's death
in 1938 and the shift from single party to
multiple political formations, caused by
a number of adverse circumstances including
economic backwardness compared to the West,
were two of the main reasons that prevented
full democratic transition. As the years passed,
there was the emergence of more liberal currents
promoting private initiative that met with the
support of the dissatisfied middle class and
less literate rural classes. Among these,
gaining the most support was Adnan Menderes'
Demokrat Parti, which, in the 1950 elections,
succeeded in ousting the old single party and
demolishing the pillars of Kemalism. Measures
such as the call to prayer in Arabic, the opening
of many mosques, and the reading via state radio
of passages from the Koran would allow religious
values to re-emerge, in contrast to the previous
statist vision. The situation is also very similar
in contemporary Turkey: on the one hand the
aspiration for a secular and democratic society as
stated in the Constitution but on the other hand
a deeply religious society that struggles
to recognize itself in national democratic
institutions. Despite the new government's
good achievements, including membership in
the International Monetary Fund, openness to both
the West and Arab countries, and decent economic
growth (9 percent annually), social tensions
simmering in the background erupted in the
famous Istanbul pogrom of 1955, when a right-wing
nationalist group clashed with a Greek minority
present in the city's suburbs, resulting in the
deaths of 30 people. Menderes' party was accused
of taking an authoritarian turn and planning the
pogrom despite its declared democratic openness.
So to restore order and prevent a religious drift
in the country, the army, as the guardian of the
Constitution, seized power by force on May 27,
1960. This date frames the first of four military
coups in the period between 1960 and 1997, during
which the secular organs of the state, represented
by the military, several times came face to face
against the confessional parties. An important
step is found in the second coup of 1971 but
especially the third in 1980, because they served
to inaugurate the so-called "Turkish-Islamic
synthesis," that is, the fusion of Kemalism
and Sunni Islam. In essence, the military, in
order to prevent the secularity of the state
from being compromised, decided to come to an
agreement with the Islamic components of society,
becoming the bridge for Islam to officially
penetrate the institutions. To make a long
story short, the situation in the 1980s was this:
after the coup was over, a consulting assembly
formed by the supreme military organ (the National
Security Council) and constitutionalist experts
was charged with drafting the Constitution.
It stated the democratic and secular nature
of the Turkish state, confirmed the role of
the supreme military organ as the protector
of social order, and expanded the powers of the
government and the President of the Republic.
The new electoral law then set the threshold for
entering Parliament at 10%, so that in 1983 only
3 parties competed for seats: the People's Party
(Halk i Parti - direct successor to the CHP), the
Nationalist Party (Mhp) and the Motherland
Party (Anap). The latter was supported by the
brotherhoods and founded by Turgut zal, who won 45
percent of the seats and became the ruling party.
Ozal's party succeeded in embodying that
Turkish-Islamic synthesis I mentioned,
bringing together the military, the brotherhoods,
and the small and medium business class. However,
persistent economic backwardness combined with
corruption and inefficiency in the state began
to foster the emergence of the Welfare Party
(Refah Partisi) founded by Erbakan in 1987 and
in which a young Erdo?an was beginning to make his
mark. The party wasn't driven by any particular
ideology but, through a team of economists,
tried to come up with the best solutions to
the problem of the broken state finances.
It was an effort that paid off, as in the
1994 local government elections the party won in
more than 20 municipalities, including Istanbul,
where Erdogan was elected mayor, and in
the July 1996 general elections Erbakan
crowned his dream of becoming prime minister. But
before long, Erbakan would be way over his head,
as conservative policies implemented by his
local administrators began to anger the military;
these included plans to build a mosque in
Istanbul's Taksim Square, a place symbolic of
the Western way of life, and a desire to convert
the former St. Sophia basilica into a mosque,
another symbol of Turkey's secular tradition
since it had been turned into a museum in 1934 by
the will of Atat rk himself. In addition, contacts
between the Welfare Party and other Middle Eastern
Islamic groups such as the Palestinian Hamas,
the Muslim Brotherhood in Egypt, and the Algerian
Islamic Salvation Front were putting the party
in a bad light in the eyes of the military. And
here we come to the fourth coup of 1997, also
called the "post-modern" coup because it was
implemented without bloodshed, with Erbakan banned
from political life, accused of stealing public
funds and inciting religious hate. The Welfare
Party was dismantled and in its place was born the
following year the Virtue Party, into which the
young Erdogan joined even though shortly before
he had been sentenced to 10 months in prison. And
given his excellent record as mayor of Istanbul,
it's not surprising that much of the population
considered his detention an injustice that would
have made him even more charming. Anyway, of the
originally planned 10 months, Erdogan served only
four since in 2001 the Turkish Constitutional
Court granted amnesty to Virtue Party members
who had been banned from public office. At
that point, the party split into two fronts:
the conservative wing of the Islamic matrix
(Saadet Partisi - Party of Happiness) and the wing
of the so-called innovators, the young moderate
reformists, of which Erdogan became the leader,
founding the Justice and Development Party (Adalet
ve Kalkinma Partisi - AKP) on August 14 of that
year. In the November 3, 2002 elections, the AKP
became the first party with 34.3 percent of the
vote, but for some reasons that I will not go into
here, Erdogan had to lead from behind the scenes,
letting his loyal right-hand man Abdullah
Gul replace him as prime minister. The AKP,
on the strength of its policy proposals
aimed at reviving the country's economic
situation hit by the 2001 crisis and rising
inflation, would set up a Muslim government,
inspired by European democracies but with a
Sunni Islamic emphasis. As Gul himself said,
"Although some of us are religiously oriented
individuals, we don't want to be defined as a
religious party. [...] We want to prove that
a Muslim-majority country can be democratic,
transparent and compatible with the modern
world." Major achievements in the early
2000s including economic growth of 5 percent
annually, diversification of foreign trade,
and an aid program for the poorer sections of
the population projected Turkey into the role
of a regional power, making it a viable candidate
for entry into the European Union, so much so that
negotiations reopened as early as October
2005. Dear Erdogan, if last year you hadn't
confined Ursula Von Der Leyen to that little couch
maybe your flag would also be in Brussels today.
Jokes aside, internally the reform of the
National Security Council was important,
remember? The supreme military organ, which was
downgraded to an advisory organ, thus lessening
the military's grip on institutions. In short, a
series of achievements that led the AKP to prevail
in the July 22, 2007 elections with as many as
46.6 percent of votes in favor corresponding to
341 seats. But on balance, the most important
achievement for the Turkish leader was that of
having succeeded in getting Gul elected to
the position of President of the Republic,
which had in fact consolidated his power over the
opposition. The situation that had been created,
however, was a harbinger of a dangerous
authoritarian drift because the government
would be able to push through laws bordering
on constitutional legitimacy without the head
of state casting any kind of veto. Starting
in 2008, a number of events threatened to
compromise the prime minister's career forever.
First and foremost, the law restoring the veil
for women in universities almost cost the
party closure for "antilaic activities,"
according to the dossier submitted by the
chief prosecutor of the Turkish Supreme
Court (Abdurrahman Yal inkaya). The rescue came
when the Constitutional Court, called to rule on
the issue, initially declared the law contrary to
the Constitution but a few months later reversed
itself on public interest grounds. Then it was
the turn of the prime minister's very strong
reaction against the members of the Ergenekon,
an alleged Kemalist-style secret organization,
composed mainly of senior army officials,
established with the aim of overthrowing the
government and seizing power in a coup. However,
an affair that remains unclear to this day,
with many accusing Erdo?an himself of organizing
everything to dispose of his political opponents.
A 2016 ruling would partially confirm these
fears by releasing most of those convicted.
Finally, it was in May 2013 that there was a harsh
crackdown on environmentalist protests against the
construction of a shopping mall in the green area
of Gezi Park near Taksim Square. On that occasion,
police intervened against the protesters using
tear gas and water cannons. The media and
newspapers loyal to the government tried to cover
up the news, but this caused the event to resonate
even more through social networks such as Facebook
and Twitter, which were blacked out. However,
the turbulent situation that had been created was
not enough to undermine the popularity of Erdogan,
who, having reached the 3-term limit and unable
to run again for the leadership of the government,
ran for the presidency of the Republic in 2014
and won with 52 percent of the votes in favor.
At that point, the "New Turkey" project desired
by the president required annihilating the last
internal opponent still capable of challenging
him. I am referring to that Fethullah Gulen
who had long ago helped him get rid of the
Kemalists and who, after the Gezi Park affair,
had instead obstructed him. His brotherhood, let s
remember: the Hizmet, was from then on branded as
terrorist (Terrorist Organization of the Followers
of Fethullah" - Fetullah i Ter r rg t ) and
targeted by government forces. The democratic
values that had brought the ruling party to
prominence back in 2002 had been betrayed, with
a society sharply divided between supporters and
opponents of the regime and a president with
little tolerance for his enemies. Frequent was
the use of Article 299 of the Turkish Penal Code,
which provided for imprisonment for all those who
offended the president of the republic; a
measure that among other things in 2021 was
declared by the European Court of Human Rights to
be detrimental to freedom of expression (Article
10 ECHR). The authoritarian drift was so obvious
that even within Erdogan's own party, scorched
earth had been made. A few years earlier, the Gezi
Park affair had cost the removal of loyalist Gul,
and in May 2016 trusted Prime Minister Ahmet
Davutoglu was also removed, due to differences in
political views, and replaced with Binali Yldrim.
Boiling tensions erupted on that Friday evening,
July 15, 2016, when a reporter from state TV
Trt began reading a lengthy statement from the
coup plotters announcing the seizure of power.
At the same time, the military had occupied the
southern bridges over the Bosphorus in Istanbul
and two jets flew over the city, spreading terror
among the population. Erdo?an declared in a live
video feed made from his smartphone that he had
survived the attack and called for citizens to
take to the streets to defend democracy. It was
hours of terror; in Ankara, the parliamentary
headquarters was hard hit by the air force
and reduced to a pile of rubble, but by the next
morning it was clear that the coup had failed, as
army units still loyal to the president managed to
restore the status quo. Even today it's difficult
to say who organized the coup. At first Aaron
Stein claimed that it was some departments of the
First and Second Armies that carried it out, along
with the support of elements of the Air Force,
Navy and Coast Guard. Another article by political
scientist Svante Cornell asserted instead that:
"had been the work of an unlikely alliance between
old-style Kemalists and G lenists." Anyway,
the casualties were about 240 civilians and a
few military personnel, nothing compared to those
who would die or be forced to flee because of the
government's harsh reaction. One thing is certain,
that was indeed the golden opportunity to
wipe out all the main opponents and more:
in fact, Gulen was blamed as the architect of
the coup, backed by the CIA. Quick parenthesis:
remember that the last period of the war in Syria
had brought relations between Russia and Turkey
closer together, meeting with a lot of criticism
from the United States. After that, a state of
emergency was declared and not only the sectors
of the military and civil service involved in
the coup were affected but also those with whom in
the previous 15 years of rule, the party had had
to come to terms in order to secure power. I leave
you with a detailed account of the various arrests
and dismissals that followed. At that point,
the icing on the cake would have been this: to
lay hands on the Constitution with a reform and
move the country toward a strong presidentialism
inspired by the French model. The coup had
caused the main opposition forces to express
solidarity with the president and show willingness
to consider the proposed constitutional reform.
However, the quorum needed to pass the amendments
wasn t reached and it was appropriate to go
through a referendum. On April 16, 2017, Erdogan
won with just 51.41 percent. A victory that,
among other things, was criticized both by
domestic oppositions, which accused the government
of electoral fraud, and by the Organization
for Security and Cooperation in Europe
and the Council of Europe. It was an outcome that
reflected the deep internal rift in the country,
where Erdo?an's legitimacy was slowly being
challenged by a general climate of protest over
arrests and repression by the authorities that
went far beyond those belonging to Fethullah G
len's organization. It was very difficult for the
oppositions to work because at the first mistake
they risked being branded as Gulenists, which
over time has become synonymous with terrorists.
Today's Turkey, which will celebrate the 100th
anniversary of the birth of the republic in 2023,
has at its leadership a president far away from
the figure the father of the Turks envisioned.
Of the Kemalist "six arrows," very few remain
intact, and among them it s clear that secularism
is no longer among the features of the Turkish
state, but still, the political involution we are
witnessing has been countered by economic growth
such that the country has become a major regional
power. That was at least until the most recent
monetary policies led to the devaluation of the
Turkish lira, culminating in the currency crisis
of 2021 and the consequent rise in inflation,
generating the risk of stagnation in the economy
due to the rising cost of living and falling
internal demand. All of this would also impact the
degree of discontent, so much so that in polls,
approval ratings toward Erdogan's actions would
have dropped from 55.8 percent in March 2020 to
38.6 percent at the end of 2021. The lowest
percentage in recent years, even lower than
in early 2019, when dissatisfaction with the
performance of the economy had caused Erdogan
to lose control of Istanbul and Ankara in local
elections. But it s good to stop here for today,
I thank you all for your attention and
I will see you in the next video. Ciao!